hello everyone I'm Alicia Malone welcome
to another episode of fandango's indie
movie guide and my big recommendation
for this week is lady Berg directed and
written by Greta Gerwig I want to go
where culture is like my research or at
least Connecticut or New Hampshire
writers living they'll give in to those
schools anyway mom should just go to
City College you know with your work
ethic just go to City College and then
to jail and then back to City College
and then maybe you'd learn to pull
yourself up and I'd expect everybody
everything
Lady Bird is a coming-of-age story
starring Saoirse Ronan as a girl who's
in her final year of high school she's
just about to go to college and she has
a tumultuous relationship with her
mother played brilliantly by Laurie
Metcalf you don't say the words fresh
coming-of-age story very often but this
really is the case here with Lady Bird
has such a wonderful sense of humor and
Greta has an immense talent at writing
characters who are quote unquote quirky
but the same time feel very real and
pack an emotional punch does mom keep me
retired week sit down I'm not tired
reading your feet you are so infuriating
stop yelling I'm not yelling oh you both
have such strong personalities ladybird
is a wonderful film and I really hope
you all get out there and see it in
support Greta it's opening in limited
theaters this weekend but it will be
rolling out soon and hopefully it's a
film we're talking about [ __ ] awards
season
Lady Bird out from this weekend what I'd
really like is to be on National
impaired but math isn't something you're
terribly strong in that we know of yet
two other quick suggestions for your in
theater watching this weekend blade of
the immortal which is the 100th feature
film from Takashi Miike if you love a
samurai action film or a tale that's
full of revenge and mythic characters
then this movie is for you it's the
story of an immortal samurai who teams
up with a young girl to help her avenge
her family's death lots of incredible
action sequences Gor as well but just
really really well-done
bleh
of the immortal check it out in theaters
this weekend's zookeeper and also the
light of the moon this is a film that
unfortunately feels very timely right
now it's about a girl who is sexually
assaulted on her way home from a night
out and it deals with the subject in a
very touching very elegant very
realistic way it'll give you some sense
of the type of trauma that sexual
assault victims go through and how their
family and friends who surround them can
also have a difficult time coming to
terms with it it also shows the
procedures that have been straight after
a woman is sexually assaulted in terms
of doctors appointments and police it
gets quite harrowing at times but it
feels like an important movie for right
now the light of the Moon out in
theaters from this weekend I am not the
one that is supposed to be on trial here
[Music]
and if you didn't catch a wind river
when it was out in theaters now's your
chance to watch it at home because it's
out this week on Fandango now this is
written and directed by Taylor Sheridan
who was the screenwriter behind Sicario
and hello high water
it's his third and what he calls his
unofficial new American frontier trilogy
and it's a gripping thriller mystery
starring Jeremy Renner and Elizabeth
Olsen
you can watch Wind River in the comfort
of your own home this weekend so
recapping on my picks this week in
theaters definitely see Lady Bird also
blade of the immortal and the light of
the Moon and at home you can see Wind
River on Fandango now I'm Alicia Malone
and since it's Halloween this week I
want to know in the comments below what
is your favorite indie horror film mine
vary a lot but I do really love the
Bubba Duke and it follows so let me know
below and I'll see you next week
you